hey you're going for michael layer one
more time
[Applause]
john while he can he won't be here long
[Music]
good to be here my name is hans kim i'm
not pumping
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
uh i mean he came here and canceled tony
i'm here to finish in java where do you
work sir
not anymore
uh but i am asian i know what they look
like but i'm not that into anime
which is unfortunate because only women
who are sexually attracted to me are
pretty into anime
i took that whole thing i forgot a
resting anime face
i'm on dance like oh very interesting
[Music]
and then i get later than anime day
which is where you pass
out holding hands
i love being an asian man i feel like
asian women
act really cocky they act like they're
hotter the nation then but we look
exactly the same
i could throw on a wig and be a seven
[Applause]
why are you bragging that you can talk
white dudes
i can [ __ ] white dudes
and all [ __ ]
i love being asian you know how do you
think asian women are created
being [ __ ] i'm a crucial part of the
sexy process
please don't try to skip me if you have
sex with me our children will be very
beautiful
half of them the other half will be
great engineers and that support too
uh asian was the nose country of chinese
from a province in china called south
korea
it's right next to the japan province
a lot of people believe hurtful things
about asians they think that we
dogs which i understand can be very
shocking because in america
dogs are treated like family members but
in asia we treat our family members like
family members
it's this real little tradition we have
where instead of buying an animal we
love our grandma
treat everyone better in asia unless
you're a baby girl
everyone else should be really good
don't look at the river
uh my asian friends make fun of me
because i like to eat generous chicken
he's my general i'll follow wherever he
leads
they're like hans isn't just a shitty
americanized version of something
authentically asian
and i'm like yeah but so am i
my favorite movie is rush hour three
i am not a racist i'm not i'm not racist
at all i'm a minority how could i be
impossible
i don't even see race i only smell it
i saw a dude reading a book in arabic on
an airplane which kind of freaked me out
but then i saw him pull the corner of
the page and put the book away and i was
like oh thank god he's got future plans
[Applause]
uh i'm not a racist i mean my favorite
marvel movie is the black panther
that gave black children a hero they can
finally look up to
and not just someone like martin luther
king jr malcolm x or harriet tubman or
derrick marshall george washington
carver nelson mandela roosevelt
copying on will smith cindy poitier
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat
i'm just jealous what are they gonna
come out with a yellow panda huh
[Applause]
but uh love being asian uh whenever
someone asks me for my name at starbucks
i like to tell them that it's ching
chong bing bong they're there
that's not your name excuse me i come
from a long line of bing bongs
[Music]
in america they stay in prison don't
drop the soap
it should be don't pick up the soap you
can drop as much soap as you want
it's the bending over where they really
catch them
even if you don't drop the soap you're
still going to get raised
you're just going to really clean hands
while it happens
why isn't this working who are these
rapists like man i want to get that kid
but he never drops
the soap
[Music]
does he have a butthole we'll never know
that's not rapists rapists are go
getters they don't take no for an answer
so uh i'm single i have uh yet to meet
my soul mate i'm beginning to think
maybe it's her fault she needs to get
outwards
she seems like a loser i think i can do
better
my friends are like dude you need to
learn how to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn how to
listen to haunts
why don't you want to hear about the
federal reserve
that's very intricate uh a lot of ladies
that i did call me a premature
ejaculator
premature taboo
i came right at the perfect time but it
felt amazing
i was talking to this girl she was like
did you know that because my vagina can
make a baby
my vagina is a 3d printer
i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer your vagina is a tray
it only brings one thing with lots of
errors
it takes nine months to print and the
whole time it's printing is complaining
[Applause]
needless to say i did not see any trades
that night
all right that's my time thank you very
much
wow